boom what's up everyone welcome to a
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site in Manchester New Hampshire
at first robotics headquarters and we
are going to be talking about
manufacturing we're to be talking about
automation we're going to be talking
about the FIRST Robotics Competition
where there are 3,800 teams this year
that are competing and building robots
and learning a lot together and they're
the Future Leaders and I'm super excited
to have Frank Merrick joining us who's
the director of FIRST Robotics
Competition hello hello thanks thanks so
much for having me on the show real safe
talk about this whole excited I'm always
excited to talk about yes
and Frank's background is super cool
he's been working in manufacturing in
doing things like procurement doing
things like actually seeing the process
out from start to finish of
manufacturing all different types of
goods from and this is all the way back
from you doing work with the United
States Air Force that's right and that
was you know that's five years of that
then there was you know five years with
Hutchinson then it was ten years with
Rockwell Automation and now it's been
almost 11 years with four onyx so this
is like this is a pretty long period of
career leading up to this point so there
is there's a lot of nuance to unpack
here let's so we're gonna jump into
manufacturing first and then we'll do
some first stuff as later on okay most
of the time when we look at things
around us I think it's really important
to have a lens of awareness to how these
things are actually built I agree
yeah the what goes into this there's an
awful lot that goes into this this kind
of thing and I'll tell you when I
started my career in when you when you
think about it very broadly
manufacturing you know you're trying to
get to a produce a certain product or a
suit or a certain outcome for for for
folks even when I back when I was in the
Air Force I was responsible for aircraft
maintenance which meant that I was
responsible for making sure that the
aircraft were ready to fly when they
needed to
and back then my product was what we
called sorties which is really a fancy
word for saying flights and so we had a
certain number of flights that we had to
get out per day for training for the the
pilots and so forth so and you had to
make sure the planes were ready to go
when they needed to be ready to go so
really in a way that was a form of
production after that I got involved in
working for an automotive sealing
company they manufacture like window
seals door seals that kind of thing for
Paris the kind of thing you would never
even maybe think twice about except when
something isn't working correctly or got
some you have some some water coming in
but of course every single product
that's not a car
there is an entire a manufacturing
process that goes along with that and
for that manufacturing process you need
to procure all the raw materials that
needs to come in you need to schedule
the workforce you need to make sure that
the products are gonna be aware they
need to be on time you need to make sure
you have enough inventory to get you
through but not so much that you're
sitting on a mountain of inventory at
the end so really all those things kind
of tied together so I did I did some
production scheduling I was in the
procurement I manages managed shift
operations I remember when I was working
for the automotive sealing company
things that the consumer would never
even think about but we had a special
type of rubber that we used in the
automotive seals that was only good
between two days after was manufactured
and seven days after it was manufactured
it had this very limited sort of shelf
life and it was impossible to put it in
the fridge but all of that had to be
sort of managed but it was it was a
great manufacturing is such a great from
my perspective a great career there's so
many things going on all the time and
you're constantly trying to meet
deadlines and trying to work as
efficiently you possibly can
yeah this is let's start going all the
way back to you know Air Force stuff
quick because this is so interesting
there was like a team of 140 ish people
that you were working with managing or
so before and this is really important
because we don't typically think of the
importance of things being super
punctual and like you know if aircraft
are needed they're needed a
they're needed right away yeah and also
keeping in mind all the time safety just
like we do at first exactly those there
are human beings that are gonna be
getting on board those airplane and we'd
to make sure they're maintained and
ready to go and ready to fly yes safely
so it was but it was a wonderful I would
I wouldn't give up my experience in the
Air Force for anything it was it was
yeah it was fantastic it really was and
those air I mean at the scale you know
we're gonna talk about robot inspection
as well but this is aircraft inspection
is this is these are big D this is a big
deal these have to be safe there's a ton
I mean we're talking dozens if not a
hundred or more parts that have to be
properly it's it's unbelievable that the
the the young folks that we had working
on those planes under the guidance and
leadership mentorship early of senior
folks just did such a terrific job so
dedicated to their to their work and
under some some very difficult
conditions I happen to be stationed at
an Air Force Base in the Upper Peninsula
of Michigan where it would get 20
degrees below zero and you still had to
go out there and do your jig you were
you need to do but such dedication on
these folks and really exciting as well
and then you started getting us deeper
into understanding the in automotive
space as well we don't when we sit in
vehicles are we really looking around at
all of the different knobs and all of
the different seals and everything that
you everything that goes into an in
automobile is designed just extremely
carefully tested the type of process
that we had to go through to get one of
our seals accepted by for example we
didn't happen to do a lot of work for GM
we did some work for Ford as well was
just incredible even even you know the
window seals it's a big deal you
wouldn't think twice about it but you
have very specific specifications that
you're trying to make because of course
the automotive manufacturer is trying to
deliver a high quality product to their
customers as well and something small
like a little window leak it's kind of a
big deal if you just span
tens of thousand dollars in an
automobile you don't wanna be driving
down the highway and just have a little
trip coming down that would be that
would make you crazy and just the the
the ability to kind of design those
seals and have them function as they're
supposed to there's just a lot of work
that goes into everything every aspect
of every little device as you've said
none that none of this happens by
accident is you're suggesting here I
mean just just every tiny little part is
absolutely designed and there's there
are jobs out there for all those folks
that want to do that kind of work which
is another reason why I'm excited to be
part of first yeah
if first is a very good sort of way for
young people to get involved in steam
careers and then and then furthermore
just they get the emotional intelligence
business entrepreneurship all these
other sort of teamwork and also there's
stuff that that launches them forward
and into these interestingly enough into
certain rules that we're talking about
even right now within manufacturing okay
I wanna I want to highlight where you
started going with us in this direction
let's talk about anywhere from through
Rockwell that you've that you've done
this okay you were indicating like okay
we have designed something that we want
to manufacture now we need to procure
resources to manufacture it we need to
make sure we're not sitting on too much
inventory you make sure that the
operations yeah tell us about it
absolutely and there so so much of this
that sounds sort of very mechanical but
when it comes right down to what much of
it is about relationships with people
yeah so we have we certainly have
designers working to design all these
products and spec them out and so forth
but when you're doing things such as
procurement which just means buying the
components the the individual components
that make up a larger a larger package
you're talking about negotiation so you
have to say okay I have certain
suppliers that are capable of providing
this product how can I work with them so
that they are happy at doing business
with us and they want to serve us and at
the same time we get decent service as a
decent price so we can keep our products
as inexpensive as possible as reasonably
possible when we get it to the consumer
and all of that really comes to down to
a lot of personal relationships yeah so
we're somewhere as something
such as sourcing or procurement can
sound very impersonal it is not in
person at all at all there's always
phone calls and video calls and meetings
as saying let's have this relationship
because really to feel comfortable doing
business with someone you need to have I
believe you need to have a personal
connection I agree and it's just it's
harder and that's why I think even with
things like you look at very could be
considered very impersonal services like
purchasing on the web buying something
on eBay or on Amazon or something or
something along those lines even in
those cases I don't know where your
experiences is on eBay but if I'm
selling something kind of eBay weren't
buying something I like to drop a little
note to the person say hey thanks you
know how are sick let me know this it's
going in the mail today just to let you
know I want to give you a heads up
because especially when you look at a
situation with eBay were where person
ratings are so important so important so
that you want to have that kind of
personal connection and nothing we do
with the when you're sourcing from a
suppliers well in building a
relationship and then you're also rating
oh man we didn't have a good batch of
right of supplies I came in from
sometimes the the difficult times really
show how how strong those relationships
can be because things like that happened
yeah and then so this I want to I want
to mention this to you because I when I
read this I was like mind blown because
I remember judging with a at at the
Silicon Valley Regional a couple years
ago with someone that worked at Apple
then they did a lot of the relationships
for further manufacturing of the Apple
hardware and there is a lot that goes
into the manufacturing of that and the
relationships as you brought up so um so
I started learning from them a little
bit and then it was crazy when I just
recently read he was like a couple days
ago I read that Apple is United Airlines
largest client Apple buys 50 business
class flights from San Francisco to
Shanghai every single day oh is that
right wow that is amazing no idea that
really is so figure right and even if
right even in these days or you could
say well why don't you just tell them
or do it by web well you can and that
helps but still getting in a room with
someone and making direct eye contact
with them being able to see their body
language being able to shake their hand
being able to go out to lunch and set
cross from them and just share a meal
when you're not tell me about your life
in Shanghai like what's going on exactly
right in so many times I'll tell you I
had this experience when I over the
summer I traveled to an offseason FIRST
Robotics Competition event in Hangzhou
and China and I Weis had heard about
sort of the FIRST Robotics Competition
culture over in China had never really
experienced it directly I'll tell you
experiencing it directly was the way to
go yeah there's only so many times we
could kind of talk about what things are
like but it was just of course it was a
magnificent fantastic experience one
I'll never forget but I had to be there
I couldn't just hear someone say oh this
is kind of what it's like over there
first-hand experience of being at FIRST
Robotics event in China versus second
hand hearing about it or watching it on
TV wait it's still it's still it's still
a great way I mean telecommunication and
web webcasts and so forth like ears you
know just it's gonna come such a long
way as since she's when I was a kid you
know there we had got four channels at
home TV and that was it and we thought
was a big deal and they but but still it
would still having that interpersonal
communication rapport I'm really
enjoying how important your making
relationships in this dialogue and I
think this is important for the people
to really understand that the human eye
to eye and learning about each other's
lives and building relationships with
all the different people that you work
with and caring about them and that's
how to really build stellar team stellar
products build value to other people in
the world I'm really happy to bring that
up okay tell us about and we're gonna
we'll get we're about to transition to
first I want to learn from you from the
ten years pre first rot with Rockwell
Rock will is a huge partner of FIRST
Robotics tremendously valuable partner
of
of first robotics competition we really
couldn't do what we do without their
support so I was working at a rockwell
automation facility as i did some it's a
procurement for them i also did did it
was a procurement engineer i really
started as procurement engineer for them
which is two titles you wouldn't think
go together but in the case there you're
trying to the procurement engineer is
trying to sort of translate and be a
person within procurement that
understands technical details and so can
and go out by like technical products
where is a may be a strategic sourcing
person with a procurement person with
less specific knowledge of what be
harder for them to kind of to kind of do
that so that was that was my first job
there but eventually i started working
for a rock automation facility that was
right here in Manchester it's actually a
right around the corner it's you could
walk there in five minutes
now that facility has since closed down
but it was it was here and I was having
the fantastic company to work for great
I happened to get I was at the time when
I got I got a phone call from a first
first robust competition team I happen
to be what working is their
manufacturing engineering and Quality
Manager and so a team called up for a
local team chaos 131 from Manchester
Central High School and they just asked
they didn't know my name they just asked
to talk to the engineering manager well
because it was a manufacturing facility
I was the only engineering manager in
the place and so I picked up the phone
didn't know you know these people had
never met them before and they said we
lot what it happened this team as they
lost their build site which occasionally
happens our teams one of the great
things about FIRST robotics competitions
is that that teams often partner with
companies tech companies in the in in
the field you know near the high schools
and so forth it provide him a build
space they provide him with mentors well
in this particular case the company that
had been supporting this team couldn't
could no longer support them with space
which happens you know companies move or
they need the space or whatever the
situation is and so it was cold call and
they said we've got this robotics team
and we're kind of looking for some help
and I kind of heard about first and Dean
came in because being from Manchester
Dean of course
is a just in in New Hampshire in the
world as well now he's just sort of a
big fixture in New Hampshire and so I
kind of heard about this robotics thing
brought him in we got him a build say so
we found him space in the basement the
we found him some mentors we got him
from some funding we actually started to
provide some parts to the kiddo parts
and one thing kind of led to another I
just I started mentoring the team from
there I started I started a couple of
FIRST LEGO League teams I started some
FIRST LEGO League junior teams this is
when your kids were also around that yes
that's right so they were they were kind
of they were they were on the on the on
the teams as well and then eventually
and I was I was just doing a lot of
first activities outside my sort of my
regular job and then an opening came up
at first world gobs competition it just
happened to be a fit they were looking
for someone with an engineering degree
and an MBA which I have you know and so
it just everything just kind of in all
the other and all the experience and one
thing and it was just the luckiest phone
call I've ever right random things
happened you say wow you know well and
there seems to be some sort of potential
essence in the universe that is ethereal
that may be helping move along the
proper pieces I'll tell you it just it
just it just felt like everything just
just happened just right I said I just
and actually there was even another
level to it because I had originally
applied to be the first lego league
junior director and they got my resume
in and it turned out at the time they
had they had just filled an opening for
a FIRST Robotics Competition deputy
director but it turned out that that
person actually backed out like they had
originally selected someone and they
said oh we're changing our mind and so
the FIRST LEGO League Junior position
had actually been filled and they said
oh this one's been filled but we have
this other one that just popped up so it
was just an incredible coincidence one
thing later but that's how life works I
mean yeah it's you never know one to get
out there did some random things are
gonna happen and set you on a lucky path
yeah you yeah and there's a lot of
things that have to happen in order for
that that lucky path to strike you get
you gotta seize the doors that are
opening
and we'll actually walk through them
listen to mentors there's tons of other
things that absolutely I mean I happen
to have the background they were looking
for the experience that they were
looking for in and really much of the
work that we do here in FIRST Robotics
Competition is production like yes and
so there's a lot of procurement going on
there's a lot of you have debt absolute
deadlines that you have to meet you have
to get a certain number of fields of the
door a certain time is very very
productive we have so much to talk about
okay so alright let's let's go um
you started mentioning this and we'll
kind of transition over with this point
that you said it's as though within the
communities where these first teams are
spurring up it's cool how they work with
the industries in mentors in their local
communities to sort of build up the
communities all of a sudden you have
actual industry workers that are
mentoring the students that are working
with them on the different engineering
design principles that they need to know
on teamwork and business strategies it's
all really exciting
and then that's how you also got
involved with bringing them into
rockaway said one of the things that
happened to me personally and we see it
reported elsewhere is that when when
industry mentors engineers scientists
technical folks or really anywhere
marketing folks is so because it takes
all kinds to make it a good first
robotics competition team it's not just
about technical of course it's about the
soft skills as well as we've been
talking about a mentor will get involved
and they will suddenly find their day
jobs more interesting so which actually
have to be pretty cool yeah it actually
happened to me I mean it just I was you
know I've been at Wroclaw automation for
I think that's because you we so often
just go after 22 or 24 whatever 18 years
of learning we just stopped learning we
stopped sort of teaching as well and
when we have young people that we see
their minds being molded into the world
and we get to sort of assist and we
learn from them at the same time that
makes us alive it's a great it's a great
citement that I would be absolutely and
that's other people and this is a common
effect is that you get involved with the
FIRST Robotics Competition team and you
may think oh man that's so many hours of
work yep
and I bet you're gonna love it okay it's
there's no question though it is it is a
great deal of work but it's it's work
that I mean if it wasn't effective at
what it did and it wasn't if people
weren't getting something out of it they
wouldn't be divided devoting so much of
their lives yeah their personal lives
they ain't going if there's there's
something so important about getting
people involved in just going one time
to attend FIRST Robotics and to
volunteer in some capacity especially as
a judge is a very exciting way to
volunteer and get out early because they
this is again this speaks to what we
just talked about you get to see young
girls young boys building and in skills
that are then going to help them so much
with their lives and such as being there
it is it sparks aliveness oh absolutely
and one of the challenges that we have
I'm glad you brought that up because one
of the challenges that we have within
FIRST Robotics Competition is you you
really can't understand it unless you
experience it directly it's very hard to
sort of yes capture on tape you can
sometimes capture a little bit as some
of the essence but once you walk into a
stadium arena or even a high school or
one of these events is being held and
you see the excitement and the energy
and the absolute passion of these kids I
mean it's it's a transforming experience
and it really is something that needs to
be experienced firsthand to get them to
get the full effect yeah okay
so let's jump because we got a lot to
talk about regarding FIRST Robotics
Competition okay
so holy cow there's this there's this
annum there's an amazing sort of process
that occurs behind the scenes every year
absolutely in order to actually come up
with the design of the competition that
occurs because we all remember the
BattleBots type stuff where it's just
robots trying it like beat each other up
and race this is this is all about
completing objectives on the playing
fields that are related to what they're
a lot of industry is doing this year is
a space-themed
write a game designed for all of the
different ages in the league's and
what's interesting about that is this is
the breaking point of the space economy
we're going to space sure and so we're
getting them ready to build objectives
we're trying to build that kind of
excitement and it just so happens that
this year of course is the 50th
anniversary of the first moon landing so
everything kind of ties together and so
yeah so it takes like for example we're
working on the 2020 game right now we've
been working on it since last year so 18
month process 18 something in that
summer 18 months 2 years depending on
how you think of when it started because
we have another concepts that work yes
we're dealing with but really what we do
because unlike maybe the like BattleBots
as you would say the FIRST Robotics
Competition and all the other programs
and first-first luckily junior FIRST
LEGO League at first Tech Challenge come
up with a new challenge every single
year yes so the way that we think about
it is we are releasing a new product
every year and their FIRST Robotics
Competition that product is going to be
released no matter what else happens it
was going to be the release the first
Saturday in January and that is an
absolute deadline because all the teams
are getting ready for it there's no
there's no oh we're gonna put on a
six-month delay no no every there is no
option but to release that game at
effort that first Saturday worldwide
simultaneously the first week in January
of course the game is top secret until
until we you know it comes out but
everything is geared toward all that all
the design all the ideation working on
sort of the the you know the marketing
materials the the production most of our
production is outsourced
and so that mean
we have to get quotes we get in our
multiple points so make sure to say how
we need to find the appropriate folks
that can do the metal work force and the
welders and the you know the the
graphics and so forth this year in 2019
we're gonna be sending out over forty
fields of into out for events where we
have a hundred and seventy five events
that we're putting on this season and
2019 in a couple months
and if within a few months time sprain
and that's why we need the 41 or 42
fields that we need that we need to
produce so in a way every every FIRST
Robotics Competition team is you I think
you mentioned we have 3800 and about 33
countries this season every team gets a
kit of parts and that kit of parts can
help set you up for basically what you
need to get a very basic robot it
doesn't get you to you know end
effectors manipulators and all that kind
of thing it doesn't do the programming
for you but you can build kind of a
basic gonna call a kit bot that really
is just on wheels and kind of runs
around every team gets that yet in a way
what we're do when we produce the fields
themselves those fields are also kitted
and we actually have the same
organization a logistics organization
that handles a kitting for the teams
kits and also for the field kits now our
kits are a little bigger they happen to
fill up an 18-wheeler you know what they
call for you from from events a handy
mark that no I know it's a different
it's a logistics organization that's
closer by and they have in a where
because the the we've got to the point
where we could we used to try to do this
like load trucks and so forth out of
this location but we've gone there's no
way this this this building you know was
built in the in the 19th century and
just there's not a lot of sort of dock
space or it's just it wasn't built for a
sort of large trucks and and and
high-volume so we had we had to go
elsewhere to kind of find that dock
space to make things a little easier and
more efficient for us Frank let me see
if I can let me see if I can come up
with a synthesis of what's already been
said because you're going super fast
okay so there's like at almost a
two-year period that's going into
the design of the games and then the
what's-what's again super captivating
about what is being done here with first
it's just the the essence of of only a
short build because that's a lot of what
goes on in in engineering and in
iteration at a lot of Industry is that
you what is six weeks is the build from
like the first Saturday in January until
the middle of February is when they're
starting to compete they're starting to
compete right towards the end of
February that's right and they get this
kit like you said um and then they fund
again this is a big process of the teams
is to fundraise money from local
industry and community parents etc helps
to be able to afford to participate in
the competitions and also to purchase
parts their compensation remark and
whatnot and then also you were used to
start telling us about the fields and
the fields are designed in a certain way
by you guys for the objectives that the
robots will achieve to be related to
things like programming and mechanical
electrical computational engineering and
design and then that really helps the
kids realize that okay I'm gonna be
doing objectives related to sensors
related to you know determining how like
but you're doing some calculus with the
trajectory of a well either like one of
those wiffle balls or there's so many
cool items that you put on fields so
many so many things important there so
when you think about it if it's FIRST
Robotics Competition robot is a
programmable electromechanical device
designed to accomplish a certain task
yeah well that applies to just about
everything right I mean if you think
about I mean this there's programming in
your in your cameras here there's
software and you're running your camera
is that every car has now has or
whatever there's a million lines of code
or something I heard some crazy amount
of software that so it's just what
they're getting into is just completely
applicable even though yeah it looks
like they're trying to score a ball in a
hole or something along that that's all
the things that they're learning
completely applicable to that what is
needed in the world today and of course
the important thing for one of the key
important things at first is is we don't
just do technology for technology's sake
we're we we want kids to
involved in something larger than just
themselves when you talk about for
example the FIRST LEGO League project
you might be doing a project about
generating clean water or keeping the
oceans safe or something along those
lines so we're we're we we don't it's
very important to us and we talk about
all the time that we want we're hoping
our students will take what they learn
and get excited about and say what are
the big problems in the world that I can
help solve now that I have this
inspiration to do more than I thought I
could do yes
I'm really happy that you brought up the
fact that every the you you it you you
change the designs every year to be
related to into objectives that are also
related to like stewardship of Earth and
also technological advancement of Earth
and like eradicating poverty and all
these really important ways for kids to
perceive what they can actually build to
solve some of these big problems this is
the 30th year that first has been going
on there's like I think half a million
kids around the world a race-baiting
that's right about it total total
at all the program levels yeah over half
a million we're gonna have something
along the lines of forty thousand FIRST
LEGO League teams and I don't know how
many countries they have eighty
countries or something it's insane it's
insane yeah and those and it's really
good to get them at a super young age of
actually one of the one of one of these
sort of awareness shifts that I've seen
any young kids is when they use like you
know MIT scratch or when they when they
actually can do something block based
programming wise and then they let the
robot perform and they go I made that
happen
when they actually design a video game
and they have the character do what they
asked another one of these is when they
look through a telescope and they see
the rings of Saturn when there's a
Miller's time they see that they're a
first-time because that's when the
awareness gets profoundly shifted and
there's no going back I'll tell you what
we've what we find we've actually
through we've we've had a number of very
generous sponsors throughout the year
and we continue to have that
partly because they see the value now
what we're doing there we just had first
robots competition had our kickoff first
for a Saturday in January and one of the
questions we asked a couple of our major
sponsors Rockwell Automation and Boeing
as well because the season it spell
itself it's a our first robotics
competition game is destination deep
space sponsored by the Boeing Company we
said what's in it for you and they
talked about all that those kind of
things for you know getting people
excited and trying to build a future
workforce yeah one of the greatest
things that we have is that we've been
working on for years now is we have been
having Brandeis University we've been
working with Brandeis University to
actually study the effects of first and
say how does first because the
scientific method you don't just hope
that something's gonna work out you want
to check it and so if we said we're
gonna use a little science on ourselves
let's make sure that the things that the
good things that we think first does for
people really does do those things for
students turns out that it does which is
great news and one of the strongest
effects that we see actually is on
female participants so where is male
participants that get involved in first
they absolutely do increase their
interest in going into STEM fields and
taking engineering courses and so forth
female responds even more so than males
it really makes a difference for those
and where where we have or very focused
on increasing minority participation is
female participation folks that are
traditionally upper underrepresented yes
insert that the technical fields and we
and I'm happy to say that we we do have
the evidence now that we really are
making that difference in word yes we're
we're because I'm glad it came out that
way because otherwise we could wouldn't
want to be talking about the study but
exactly we got to actually have facts
and the numbers and make sure that this
is actually the future is here it's just
not evenly distributed all right so when
you have the opportunity for a kid to
potentially use a skill like learning
how to program in virtual reality we're
learning how to make block chain
protocols they're just not exposed to
the fact that they can do it yet
and so this is around kids around the
world in lower or middle socioeconomic
statuses they can actually be pulled up
through programs like FIRST Robotics and
then find themselves earning a hundred
plus thousand bucks a year absolutely
yeah and so that this is the case
studies we say it we we say it all the
time
first is the only sport where everyone
can go pro yeah and so there's there's
really let me participate on a FIRST
Robotics Competition or for any first
team at all FIRST Tech Challenge for us
luckily they can all go pro and do this
for a living and you can't say that
about football there's nothing wrong
with football baseball great activities
yes yes the kids number of kids that are
gonna make a living off of that tiny
yeah yeah that's insured this is very
interesting you bring it up there's no
sort of like basketball or football
baseball soccer etcetera where that
where there's there's only pro and like
semi-pro but there's no like industry
related you know there are some I guess
you can go and work in the different
sporting facilities where sure Pro right
but then but really where you're
bringing this perspective of like
there's millions and millions of jobs
where there's you know working in in
robotics or automation or so many jobs
we can't if they can't even be filled
I mean companies that are looking for
and we had this experience ourselves
looking for folks not really at the the
FIRST Robotics Competition levels
luckily of when we have openings we have
a lot of very enthusiastic applicants
which is great but you know trying to
source for example an IT professional
but just it's there is a lot of demand
out there and there are just not enough
people to fill all those jobs and that's
we're trying to fill that we're trying
to create that pipeline and fill that
gap okay I want to get a little more
technical alright so this is that this
is all extremely important on building
the future and have building helping
build the youth to care about the future
now I want to do a little technical you
just had a T robot inspectors that were
training here that's right and this is
an important part of this process is
that
robotic kits that are given to the teams
then you know they are you release the
game design so they now know okay this
is what we're we're building the robot
to complete these specific objectives on
the playing field that are going to earn
us this many points and they have to
keep it in a certain what is the size
again of the FIRST Robotics Competition
robot typical size would be like about
three feet by three and a half feet
something along those lines maybe 60
inches tall it changes from season to
season based on sort of the needs of the
game yes but if you think of something
maybe the size of a like a small like
freezer like a compact freezer something
goes like kind of like a mini fridge
like a mini fridge yeah exactly
typically in that roughly that size and
and for total weight probably looking at
no more than 150 pounds or so because we
have weight as well of course yes so
weight limits 150 about that but a lot
of mini fridge or so yeah and then so
now okay so now what's happening is not
only do they have to fit in the size and
weight restrictions but then the robot
inspectors that you know that you're
training there's certain again if the
team's fund raise enough money which
they're totally incentivized to
fundraise more money they can add better
and better quality gadgets and gizmos to
the actual BOTS so they can Oh complete
those objectives but then robot
inspectors have to come and make sure
that the robots are compliant with first
yeah tell us about this so there's
there's a the robotic the robot section
of the game manual talks about how the
robots puts puts limitations on how the
robots can be designed is we're saying
has to be a certain size this year you
can only reach a certain distance
outside sort of your the perimeter of
your robot there's a limitation on there
you can't do things like toss certain
objects that we don't want to have
tossed like I'm the on the field and we
also many of the rules really are there
for probably all the rules are for
safety and fairness and so you have to
use a certain style of battery you can't
you can't it kind of bring anything you
want to use it as a power
you're limited on terms of the types of
motors that you can use because we don't
we want to make sure that the robots are
not overpowered and to kind of minimize
the chance of anyone getting hurt so you
know so we we all those rules are in
place for as I said for safety reasons
also for fairness because we don't want
it there's a sort of a limitation on the
amount of money that you can spend on a
robot because we don't we do want the
team's building the robots themselves we
don't want a team's going to some
manufacturer and say here's $20,000
build me a really nice robot that
wouldn't that would be kind of defeat
the purpose the purpose of the program
and so when we have and so teams can
think about this as a set of
specifications they're saying here you
could we want you you want to accomplish
a certain task you have to do it kind of
within this envelope yeah just as if you
go to a pick one you're gonna outsource
manufacturing somewhere in you want to
purchase something you go to the the
possible manufacturing facility and say
I want it to look like this or this this
is kind of your limitations you need to
like color within these lines you don't
want them coming back and say well we
decided to ignore what you said and just
kind of did their own thing no no that's
not that's not how it works you know you
have we want you to be creative but
within creative within things that keep
things from a FIRST Robotics Competition
perspective fair in and primarily safe
because we're always concerned about
safe like a rover or a satellite needs
to fit certain components inside of it a
certain size a for viewing exactly
exactly right they don't have an
unlimited weight that they can make and
ship to Mars right there's something
look it's gotta weigh this much or no
more than this same it's just the same
prints and there's like the certain ways
that they want to potentially analyze
the soil composition so that they need
the certain tools on board right exactly
the same principle and so here today we
have our lead robot inspectors there's a
lead robotic specter at every event so
every over 175 events going to have a
lead robot inspector working for that
person is a number of other a robot
inspectors and their jobs are the team's
bring in their robots and the idea is
that they are
making sure that folks looking at the
robot doing the inspection making sure
that all the rules the required rules
are being filed but it's more than
they're not just police right so they'll
they'll say is you've got a problem here
let's see is there a way that we can
work with it you know work it so that we
can get you compliant because the goal
is to not keep keep people off the field
but get them on the field following all
the rules yep yep you definitely started
breaking it down it's just nuts the
motors the battery there's there's a
sensor limit as well as the right is
that sure there's no specific sensor
limit there are for example we talked
about there is a dollar limit like how
much you could spend like on an
individual component a an individual
because we don't we don't is so that
kind of but really sensors that's that's
yeah teams could go those they can go
nuts with but there isn't you know a
total dollar limit so they use them in
such a way that they can yeah and the
sensors like uh you know like obvious
there are some things that are just
prohibited like certain levels of lasers
and you know we just want people to be
safe you can use grease you know that
kind of thing because I don't want to
mess up the field and and yeah so you um
there was also a sort of it was really
interesting I believe it was at
stronghold which was three 2016 3 years
ago 33 years ago yeah them it was
interesting with that just with that
game design we saw well I remember
seeing a lot of robots that that the
team's chose to either build and use the
hundred fifty pounds and use the three
foot by three foot sort of mini-fridge
style size or some went really thin very
very low on the ground very low like
we're only talking this high yes right
so there's just a pic and a right and so
and so that was that was a specific
reaction to something that we had put in
the game which we call the which was
called the low bar and so what teams
found was that there was an advantage to
you going under that low bar and then
they would go under it and then after
they got past it they would pop open
open they would open they would that's
how they would shoot the projectiles
right it's a lot a lot of teams did that
now that's course that's that's a design
trade-off
they're saying oh yeah I want it's cool
it takes maybe a little extra work to be
able to kind of go compact and then go
out yeah pop pop open so that but that
was one approach that many teams did so
we try to put challenges in the game as
best we can so there is no obvious
solution yes like there are trade-offs I
really want yeah so that's actually a
really good point is that the more that
you put interesting design trade-offs in
the more crowdsourcing of good ideas can
come yeah that tackled objectives in
different ways yeah we have we see so
many and many teams published
information about their progress yes hey
we're working on this or we're doing
this there's even a group or a group of
folks that put together a challenge what
they call the robot in three days
project they will they will mentors
typically some students as well but
they'll try to test out some concepts
try to try to finish a robot in actually
in three days and this is this isn't it
very cool that when when you dislike a
hackathon for you for a robot for first
and what's good about that is when you
have this sort of like you're set a
conscientious deadline three days then
you work really hard with a group of
people with teamwork and with operations
and manufacturing engineering design
prototyping cetera you get it done not
only does it feel really good to be able
to say that you've done things like that
but then you realize kind of what
industry like you know hackathons and
processes are you you know this six week
time crunch you give this is for
specifically FIRST Robotics Competition
FIRST Tech Challenge FIRST LEGO League
first likely junior have longer sort of
builds and periods of time - yeah that's
right and actually we're making a change
to this well where we have had we have
been FIRST Robotics Competition has been
the only program and first of the four
programs that had a specific build
deadline yeah the other programs you
would you could build until competition
the deadline was when you need to put
the robot out on your first match that
would that was the deadline we spent a
great ends we still have that for 2019
season six weeks is still the limit we
made a sick
if ik indecision we've actually been
working on it for a few years now
they're starting in 2020 there will be
no stop build day so you are still under
you have major change for us and for the
end for the community and you still of
course do you still have a deadline that
deadline is when are you going to be
going to your your first competition and
I'll tell you the reason why we made
this a primary reason we have spent a
lot a lot of time in the last few years
working on equity diversity and
inclusion and when we looked at the stop
build day through that lens there are
other lenses to use to kind of look at
the different ways to look at it but
when we looked at it through that lens
we recognized that many of the top teams
probably most of the top teams not
exclusively but almost certainly most of
the top teams actually built two or more
robots oh yeah so they have a little
money right to be able to spend in that
dollar limit that you have on one robot
they can do that multiple time right
because the the dollar limit is on your
competition robot and your competition
and and what you need to back up you
when what you need there's a point when
you're when it's time for stock build
day we would put the robot in a bag and
say I'm not touching it again to a
competition well teams that are that are
well resourced would put that one robot
in the bag and then keep working on the
other robot and one of the one of the
advantages that multiple robots has for
example in this it probably is not
immediately obvious is you can continue
to work on software and that kind of
thing but also you get in drive practice
and so driving driving skill is so
important to doing well in our
competitions that often can can kind of
make the difference so you had teams
with more resources that were out there
driving away where teams that yeah yeah
with limited resources resource teams
that get their sad robot sitting off in
a corner a bag in there like what do
what do you do there's nothing we can
feel competition right there's nothing
there's nothing and there's also the
resource head the resource set teams can
also then have things like their own
practice fields it's like that exactly
right and then they all can also do
things like they can use a robot on the
on the field that can potentially can
they could they use a different no they
can't use the other robot know they have
so the other robot is really just like a
practice
about but we did have some rules
allowing like bringing in a certain
amount of additional weight or swapping
out components that kind of thing so
that whereas you do have one competition
robot that you enter and in each event
but the range is on the way it's this
very significant you're very sort of a
cultural change for us because we so
long have been doing it with the
limitation but when we looked at it
getting serious about equity diversity
inclusion we looked at and we said this
is the right change for not without its
downsides no question and we heard a lot
from the community some saying this is
great
some saying I this is too much I can't
because there's some value in having
sort of an imposed limitation of a
magenta line and red line yeah because
we because now they can tweak it all the
way up to competition right and so they
might be whereas so whereas you know if
you're you're the spouse of an FRC FIRST
Robotics Competition mentor you may have
been able to say okay this is only first
it's only for six weeks that I won't be
seeing her you know she's she's off
doing the robot thing yeah where I'm
back you know whatever this the
situation would be and she's off doing
that don't see her but now they're
saying well now you're extending that
time but but the but what were the
approach that we're taking is that this
puts scheduling in the hands of the
teams they're completely making their
own decisions so if they wanted to if
they really would couple ways to
approach this if they wanted to they
could they could say yeah probably a way
we would not suggest but they could say
I'm gonna work as hard for for ten weeks
as I'm doing for six weeks that sounds
like a recipe to burnout for burnout to
me but they might make that choice or
they can say I'm gonna take the amount
of work I was doing over six weeks and
spread it out over ten weeks so instead
of a five day a week activity that I
have it's only a three-day week and I
might be able to that might lead to
completely different extracurricular at
the same time it's music or sport or all
exactly right because we have especially
for the students and that's a great
point about students as well of course
is that their participation in FIRST
robotics competition or any of our
programs is course competing with a foul
and other things that they could be
doing including sports and music and all
that which all we encourage her want
well-rounded students we don't want them
just doing a robot said doesn't it's not
gonna lead to a good high price one area
right it's not gonna be a lead to a good
outcome you you know another huge
principle of what you're teaching us
right there is that now it levels out
the playing field in terms of now the
teams can work on the robot and practice
with the robot leading up to the
competitions instead of just the
resource wealthy ones could absolutely
right so because as you pointed out some
of our teams have like full full fields
or something similar to a field and now
they can invite other teams to say come
on it's open all the time there's no
restrictions you don't have to worry if
you have just one robot you could still
go practice with a practice after that
what would be a tradition interesting
sweet there's also going to be a lot of
time that they can then you're adding
time then for them to be able to learn
and iterate as well which is cool so
it's actually opening things so once so
it's the iteration is so important yeah
now if you ask me what kind of what the
practical effects are gonna be we're
gonna find out because human nature
being what it is it wouldn't surprise me
if many teams are still scrambling at
the end of you know the day before the
competition is a user scrambling before
right but at least at least but if
they're in that position you know maybe
they they didn't have to worry about so
much scrambling early on or the team's
can take it really any way they want
they could say you know we're not we're
gonna start working on the robot until
two weeks into the season so it'd still
be a six-week build but we're just gonna
it's really it's putting teams are more
in charge of their own destiny now yeah
and and honestly yeah you know some
teams are just they would rather there's
there some sense that maybe they would
rather have first say no here's your
deadline yeah rather than going the
other way but I think overall it's going
to be a great move yep yep I think so
too
and it's really good to all it's a there
used to be this you need to bump Bank it
up and seal it and you don't have to do
so many rules and so yeah it's kind of
nice right it's own in that one of the
things that we're trying to do is is
long term reduce the complexity at first
robot
because there's still a lot of rules but
getting rid of we're doing our best but
but getting rid of stop bill day and all
the rules that go along with it that's a
whole set of rules that we don't have to
you're no longer than opening things up
for kids to participate in other things
putting right Mack do additional bill
time spread out the bill time that's
right very interesting stuff more
iteration they can drive more and the
reason we announced this I think in
October or November but anyway in the
fall for 2020 yeah because we wanted
teams to take this season to think about
the 2019 season to think about how they
run the teams what's important to them
which way they want to go because it's
so it is so easy in first robotic
competition in life to just get into a
rut well we've done this it's worked for
the last ten years we'll do the same
thing again well and now we're saying no
no I mean really think about it you may
want to do the same thing again but take
a breath to say okay I now have this the
landscape has shifted formulaic change
right think about all think about what's
important to you and what's the best way
to reach those goals yes now that you
have a longer sort of span of time to do
it you and you may do exactly what you
were doing before but but I think that
many teams are looking and say oh we can
do things a little differently maybe we
can do things with less stress and we
can still kind of achieve our objective
okay let's talk on culture because this
is really important there's a there's
this FIRST Robotics culture of gracious
professionalism we just had Woodie
flowers on the show and there's a
coopertition this sort of idea of being
graciously professional so that you can
and express a great amount of love and
compassion for other people and other
teams with providing parts or providing
a help and guidance mentorship but still
compete we're on the field that's such a
beautiful way of seeing the world of how
we can work together it's it's and I
think that it's something that is fairly
unique to FIRST Robotics Competition to
all the first programs as well because
all the programs have that gracious
professionalism built in the idea that
you can as you said you can compete
while still being compassionate or
it's your opponents now this is probably
not the kind of thing that you might see
in NASCAR or in so I try to imagine I'm
trying to imagine I mean it's not a I
know you've been to many events you've
seen it it's not unusual for someone a
team to tell the announcer in the pits
we're missing this part or we missing
this tool the announcement goes up in
ten different teams will come running
over to try to help you say here's a
tool can you imagine like an open a
NASCAR situation where some NASCAR team
says I'm missing this tool and the other
NASCAR teams are coming right now maybe
they would I don't know work but I think
it would be rare it's like a shift to an
abundance mindset on the planet rather
than the scarcity and we see things for
example the pie is growing for everyone
and so that if I have exceeds so first
robotics competitions still want to win
but they want to win against opponents
that by doing their best against other
teams that are also doing their best and
sometimes you need to help those other
teams do their best
oh you know off the field this kind of
thing that I'm talking about but it but
but and also like I needed but there
have been times like during during
matches where an alliance this this
happened in a Finals event recently I
can't remember where it was where an
alliance recognized that another
Alliance needed to take a timeout but
they that other lines had already used
their timeout
so the first Alliance took their time
out so that the other Alliance could
have more time to get their robot up and
running I mean when would you gracious
voice is that yeah that's I believe
because you wanted to you don't want to
win because the other guy had a broken
robot you want it you want to do well
you want to do your best welcome yeah or
sharing component sir it's just it's so
important to us in the culture I mean
we've been around you said we're going
on the first itself going on for 30
years and certainly at first robotics
comes in 26 20 I don't know what the
total number is right now but something
around 26 years but the we've had this
people are so fanatic and engaged many
people with FIRST Robotics Competition
you can really engage it at any level
you want you could just go to a
competition
check out a competition you have a lot
of fun it we get like a lot of a lot of
parents doing that that kind of thing
engaging a devil you can get much much
more engaged we have for example I'm not
sure if you aware there's been a
tradition going on a championship where
there's a Robo prom yeah it's actually a
program that goes on a championship and
now at both locations a team puts on a
prom they do it for fundraising for
themselves to raise money for the
following season
they sell out every year they have a
thousand attendees everybody goes and
has a blast you know at this problem it
has nothing first headquarters had
nothing to do with or it's just
happening on its own and if one of them
one of the reasons why is not only to
build the culture within first and then
the teams but also because sometimes
they have to miss their their proms due
to the championships competition right
and that was I think that was originally
the how that was kind of kind of started
up but it was it was just but it's been
going on for years and this is so cool
these little additions of culture
building we have a number of different
webcasts they go and they have nothing
to do we had we don't produce them it's
just this individual groups are saying
we want to have a web kit like what
happened in first is let's have a
webcast like do a show and get some
experts and talk about it there's even a
you've heard a fantasy football there's
a fantasy first league that's where you
could go and pick teams that's so that
yeah it's it's it's insane no it's not
like how many people are participating
in there now that's funny yeah yeah it's
it's it's it's unbelievable but people
take it and they run with it because
they're all these different aspects of
first not just about the robot yeah
correct
more than robots yeah yeah all right
okay on the way out I want to ask couple
questions what you kind of started
indicating towards this towards this the
competition's that are played at these
hundred and seventy seventy-five events
that are gonna be played in just a
couple months in like three months or so
and that's just for FIRST Robotics
Competition then there's all the
thousands of tens of thousands other all
my students that are being played in
other leagues now they're sort of this
they win at these events and the ones
that win the different awards there's
there's different awards that are won
there's you know inspire
words that are one our Chairman's awards
that are one there's motivation awards
or engineering notebook Awards right
there's these sort of different awards
and these winning these awards is kind
of what gets you into the next step and
gets you closer to the championship
round now yeah yep and then you have you
went from having a single championship
now you have to touch it because there's
so many teams I'll tell you what they're
the reason the big impetus for that is
our championship is the first
championship is a little bit different
and then other sort of sports
championships so we it's a experiencing
championship is so overwhelming and
meaningful for so many of our students
we wanted to make it more available yeah
more broadly available so as at the
FIRST Robotics Competition level we went
from we had about I think was maybe we
had 600 teams or something like that
before we went to the two championship
now we have two championship locations
first championship Houston first
championship Detroit both of which have
400 so that means we can get 800 teams
about a little more than that at these
events that have these teams experience
this and we want to make that experience
unforgettable yes and the the for
example last year between the two
locations we had a total of 70,000
people attend those championships which
is a huge number and you walk into this
huge committee and you're just special
v's our first time there you're
absolutely lonely blown away but we are
a little bit different in that you don't
to get to championship you the your only
path is not I'm trying to figure out how
to put this appropriately you cannot win
an award and still get the championship
because we have what we call waitlist
slots
and for us and that's a very important
part of the experience we really want
because with the level of competition
there is enforced FIRST Robotics
Competition and the wide variety of
resources and so forth that teams have
available we don't want to say to any
team ever your chance of getting to
first championship is zero I'm really
sorry so we always want to have at least
nonzero chance now the chance might be
very small but we'll want to have a
nonzero chance of those teams being able
to get there yeah and so this year for
2019 I'm not sure what the total is
we'll probably have between at each
location probably between 30 or 40 or so
something in that range of weightless
slots where teams that want to go they
just say they'll put me on the wait list
for championship and we actually have a
weighted lottery system that we use to
select those teams so the longer that
you have been a team since the last time
you made it to Championships you get
your number tossed in the electronic hat
that many times so if you haven't been
to champs in ten years your electronic
number gets sauce in ten times or
whatever the count yes where as you went
last year you wouldn't have you know
there's this there's a there's some a
couple things to measure there I mean
one of the things to measure is of
course the benefit of having teams that
didn't win in wards 10 championships
there's a lot of potential benefit yeah
there's also the kind of like benefit of
of enticing them to potentially you know
strategize and work harder to win awards
so that they don't just rely on a wait
list there's also so we don't
necessarily want to go to champs and
then get crushed by other it's there's
there's a lot there is a lot that that
goes into that and we find a
championship just to be from what we
reported from the teams just very
inspiring yes for every team that goes
and we say you know every team that go
into temperature every team every team
going to championship probably doesn't
deserve to win there's no team I know of
that does not deserve to be inspired and
so we want to make that when it's a good
way to put it that we want to make that
possible and at the same time we talked
about because every no matter how we
structure the rules no matter how big
the tournament that particular event is
are all small it is there is always
somebody there is going to be teams that
are in the bottom 10% of the right yeah
no matter how great their heart rate
they have yeah so it's so what we try to
do and this this is a phrase that
actually came from one of the first lego
league engineers is kind of the back of
the bus experience so we want every team
that goes to an event when they get back
on the bus
to say that was worth it I can even
anyway
even if there nothing worked on there is
something we try to give them something
that they can hang their head on arm a
robot finally you know completed a full
match without right whatever that is we
want to give them some legitimate win
not just the kind of a pump up win
they're talking about a win literally a
legitimate win that they can point to
and say we did we accomplished this this
one task we didn't do great in the
rankings you know what next year we're
gonna come back and we're gonna do
better so that's kind of inspirational
thinking that they could point to say we
got good shot on that the tiny bit of
additional Drive that someone can feel
from accomplishing something or hearing
the good job right someone else that is
a huge motivator to drive forward so
that happening at all levels of
participation is really really crucial
but also to open things up for people
that may find themselves potentially
deciding to want to endeavor into
something else because they may not be
find themselves so good at a certain
aspect shirting 'he's okay let's let's
do we do a couple of normal questions on
the way out of our shows and I'm excited
to hear some of your thoughts about them
okay one of the questions that I'm
finding interesting to ask people is
about forces that sort of transcend the
human experience so some people
reference God some people reference all
that is some sort of cosmic or universal
spirit something that's past the three
dimensional reality what do you think
transcends us that's a great question I
find that I have had I'll tell you about
a transcendent experience that I had and
then first in and what it was what it
was like and it really it was
legitimately for me transforming so I
had I had been mentoring a FIRST
Robotics Competition team for a few
years I had a rookie FIRST LEGO League
team in a town nearby my home and we
worked really hard with his team rookie
team first first their first year
everyone's first year in the organiz
we went to a local competition and I
think there were like 15 teams there was
actually at the University of New
Hampshire over in Durham New Hampshire
and during the during the event they
were doing course first little you know
it's a single day kind of event and
there is you know there's a number of
you know judging such as they go to we
were doing pretty okay like it was you
know I thought it was going to okay
we're doing okay on the table we were
doing okay in the judging sessions and
at the end we got to the awards and we
went through they started going through
all the sort of the awards that they
were giving out and they went through
the technical awards and we didn't want
anything and they went through the you
know the the project awards and we
didn't get anything and the way through
they're good didn't we didn't get
anything in so in my hot mind I was
actually rehearsing a little script that
I was gonna say to the kids and say you
know what you get we didn't win any
awards it's not important we looked
about the experience we learned it's
your first year I could see that you
guys were having fun and so we're gonna
come back in it and then they got to the
champions award which is a top award for
the FIRST LEGO League and they started
reading through it and and I I started
to get just I they were they went
through this this you know description
of the award is and so forth and then
the judges really loyally I was out
literally I was in my mind I was at that
moment practicing what I was going to
say to the kids
yeah and they said our name yeah and
they said I was sitting down I literally
I got dizzy I mean I'm not kidding I got
this area if I'd been standing up I
would have fallen over I could not
believe it and at that moment I had
because I realized that it kind of set
up a little wall in my mind about
between between you know what was
possible and what was impossible with
with students of this age and that
emotion that expect was the experience I
think was that wall just being wrenched
from its foundations and suddenly for me
personally is like this is fantastic and
it's that kind of for me that was a
transcendent experience and we see that
all often times in FIRST Robotics
Competition
be walking around the the pits and I'll
be talking to uh I'll be talking to a
student as happened to me several times
I'll be talking to a particular student
on a team and they just seemed really
excited to know they'd know other stuff
and they know what's going on and then
later on the ceremony they'll be
announced for Dean's List it's like this
is fantastic
yeah so for me there's those kinds of I
can't I can't really explain at home
ideologically through how that happened
but I'll tell you guys a little II I was
legitimately ready I was dizzy I'm not
making them I was like sitting down I
was especially getting ready to do
anything and then they win them and then
they would the top award it was just and
boom just a great and what
transformational for these kid I've
never seen kids so excited gosh it was
just it was it was really it was
transformation glad you brought your
experience with that up I've had also
similar experience of an all-girls FIRST
Tech Challenge team that won the inspire
award and when and that was my first
time judging and when and when I when I
you know when they're running through
high fiving I'm like - yeah it's you
know and I'm just like oh my gosh like
thirteen to seventeen year old girls are
just like they know so much more about
engineering and designing robots then I
do I'm like awesome how do we yeah how
do we get this around the world more so
on the glide I'm glad you brought that
up
okay this wouldn't be simulation if we
did ask you do you think we're in a
simulation boy that's a great question I
guess I wouldn't know I guess I would
know of that and it's it's actually it's
actually funny this is just thinking of
when I first became director of FIRST
Robotics Competition because I was
deputy director for a while and I became
director and I saw a comment on one of
the message boards that said something
about not sure if if I was like my
person was a construct or something that
like marketing had invented or something
lately created this personality or
something and I posted a blog saying hey
I saw they said I said to the best
my knowledge I'm a real person but I
posted I've linked it to the you know
you've heard brain-in-a-vat
right yeah and so I've linked I linked
to the brain-in-a-vat entry on Wikipedia
to the best of my knowledge I don't
think this is a simulation but I guess I
guess it's not outside the realm of
possibility yeah I love it I love it
it's such a good thought experiment and
yeah I feel like I'm constantly leveling
up yeah I'm laying up in a game and I I
love I love doing the hard work to level
up gain the experience points oh yeah
something we talk about a lot on the
show is making sure that the next
generation of of leadership is striving
to be their best selves in the world we
need them absolutely especially with
when you you look in the culture I'm
sure every generation probably says this
but you you look at it a culture and the
way the culture is is going right now or
you just get the sense that many folks
are just kind of hoping that good things
happen to them hope first actually
seizing my opportunities and I think
going out and working and working and
more then it's also up to us not only
for them to you know work really hard
and the communities to help a lot with
but then but then it's also up to us to
do things like help with the planetary
design and architecture where the
resource flows and frameworks for all
people the baseline is constantly
increasing so that people have maximal
degrees of economic freedom to pursue
what actualizes them I agree and in and
one other element of that is from within
a FIRST Robotics Competition standpoint
of course is mentoring is so important
it's just a critical part of the program
yeah and it really it really transcends
showing students how to how they might
want to put together a robot it's about
helping them win it life not just win in
matches yes
but saying look you've got to go out and
you know what you're gonna have to do
some things that you may not want to do
yeah but that's how you you you learn
and get ahead right yeah yeah and you
make yourself it make it so much easier
on you and
long-term if you do some some of those
hard things yeah up front yeah face
adversity and learn and grow
yeah get through it this has been super
enlightening super lame talk thank so
much about manifesto for having me
talking about the complexity of that I
think about FIRST Robotics Competition
and all the complexity in that as well
this has been a lot of fun for ya as
well thank you so much thanks for having
me on the show
glad you had a good time thanks everyone
for tuning and we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear from you give us your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode and if you're interested in more
first any programs at first we have
programs from 6 to 18 years old
please go visit WWF arson spires org
check us out and we've got all kinds of
we've got we got something that'll work
for you first inspires org links in the
bio check it out like we talked about in
the episode even that tiny bit of
volunteering and seeing how children's
minds are being molded through things
like this in the world is super
enriching go and check it out and let us
know your thoughts and thank you very
much for tuning in build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love and we will see you
soon peace that was say alright thanks
that was good thank you it was a lot of
fun